as a live look this morning from inside
NASA's control room just minutes from
now the only satellite ever to orbit
Saturn will be destroyed the Cassini
spacecraft has made countless
discoveries about the second largest
planet in our solar system but in just
over 10 minutes NASA will send it
crashing into Saturn's atmosphere on
purpose
Jamie yuccas is at NASA's Jet Propulsion
lab in Pasadena California where the
team that launched Cassini will watch it
come to a fiery end Jamie good morning
good morning NASA is usually trying to
keep spacecraft from the Explorer
exploding right but you can see all
these people are here to watch one
disintegrate over the planet that
they've studied for so long that's the
program they're watching right now the
project is appropriately called
Cassini's grand finale and liftoff of
the Cassini spacecraft it took nearly
seven years for Cassini to make the 2
billion mile trek to Saturn but it was
well worth the wait the satellite has
been back more than 450,000 stellar
images the pictures show the planets
many moons a monster storm rolling
through even a glimpse of earth
reminding us just how vast our solar
system is this is the room where you
guys have been monitoring for almost two
decades that's right since Cassini
launched in 1997 project scientist
Linda's Volker has been a part of
Cassini since it was just an idea on
paper why do you think the everyday
person is so interested in these types
of events I think with a mission like
Cassini you get a sense of being right
there in the Saturn system close enough
to reveal these incredible worlds so
there's beauty as well as science in the
data more than 600 gigabytes of data led
to groundbreaking discoveries including
the fact that one of Saturn's moons has
a frozen ocean lurking behind its crust
now after nearly 300 orbits Cassini is
running low on fuel NASA was worried
about the satellite crashing into and
contaminating one of Saturn's
potentially life inhabiting moons with
human microbes shake my hand
I now have your microbes oh you now have
my microbes so the agency decided to put
Cassini on a crash course with Saturn's
atmosphere let's just plunge it right
now plunge it right in and that's to
protect several several the really
spectacular objects that are in that
Saturn system we don't want to infect
them with our life because we want to go
there and we don't want to discover them
even though it's the grand finale
Cassini's mark on science lives on the
end of Cassini is really sort of a
beginning for looking at all the data
for Cassini the people will go out and
support our mission so endings often
have a beginning and the Cassini mission
is no exception Cassini is traveling at
a relative velocity of 76,000 miles per
hour so its demise will be pretty quick
now telescopes here will be watching the
burnout from a billion miles away and it
might be hard to see because it's around
noon Saturn time to ensure that the
mission goes off without a hitch
JPL scientists are going back to a
tradition that dates back to 1964
they're eating lucky peanuts Nora we're
like why she knows okay
yeah they're very good with raisins yeah
thank you very much one of the old
favorites yes and raisins get the salty
and the sweet that's right yeah very
high calorie but it's good